Oh, happy holidays.
Happy holidays.
How we doing, everyone?
How we doing?
Yeah.
Minto, you look so beautiful.
I think so.
I think it would be nice if people explain their outfits,
you know, what they're kind of thinking behind their faces.
um get up what was what was your thoughts minto behind this
my thoughts was um wota santa and my candy canes are my my
headlikes beautiful who is who is santa's oshi rudolph no
way no wait probably probably i think i'd have to put on
like a rudolph nose that's like you know the It's the
Oshigir.
You did that Oshikatsu?
Yeah, yeah.
Apparently I've got my reverb on.
Sorry, guys.
I'm back.
No, you're a Christmas ghost.
Yeah.
We are three ghosts paying you guys an overnight visit.
Oh.
Hey, you guys still in my gig.
What the?
Yeah.
Yeah, sorry.
Phoebe, what about you?
I like this light fringe.
kind of uh thoughts behind this paris fashion week um get up
it is my festive unibrow oh very nice looks like you're
licking my candy can i was i was i was right in my face i
was just like i know i'm so sorry you guys no no no thank
you for the snack follow proper etiquette you know don't
bump
I can't please both of you at once.
You got two hands.
You can do it.
That's your pen lights and we're just eating it.
It's a bit rude.
Yeah.
No, I think it's even rude that I'm spreading them in your
face.
You know, you gotta follow the concert etiquette, right?
Yeah.
What is going on at these Christmas concerts?
All sorts of things.
of joy yeah what have you what have you been up to over the
holiday season febi you've been you've been up to anything
nice well uh i i went to anime week in atlanta oh and
actually i got a visit from some christmas angels during my
concert at anime week in atlanta i think some people really
enjoy that how could that be how could that they were really
really they were so cute and so pretty and so hot though wow
christmas angels hot yeah oh sorry they made me feel warm
and fuzzy during the cold winter season oh hot like hot
cocoa i see oh yes exactly exactly i got it i get it what
about you minco um i was a little just a ways a little ways
from phoebe i was at holiday And, yeah, I did a concert
there too.
It was lots of fun.
And then I was like, you know, okay, one day I want to apply
to be one of the ghosts of Christmas.
Like, you know, I'll probably be like Ghost of Christmas.
I don't know.
What do you guys think suits me?
Past, present, or future?
Oh.
I feel like...
I'm scared.
I think my chat would say past because they're like, you're
old.
But they aren't all ghosts old technically.
Like they all are like of the past.
I'm forever 19.
Like I don't stop.
I'm stuck like this.
Ghost of Christmas.
I think you're ghost of Christmas.
Freaky.
They need to add another ghost.
I was going to say present because your present.
is a present, but I mean, I think goes to Christmas Freaky.
I think Vicky's on to sleep.
Well, I can't argue that.
Yeah, we were also at home that, too, right?
I was.
We got to meet a lot of you sweet people.
It was the first time I've done one of those, like, wheeling
me around.
It was really fun.
Got to meet Shroud of the Hedgehog's eyes after cut.
Tell us about it.
Hold it right.
Tell us everything.
Oh, my God.
So I was like, I was like shaking and sweating.
Anyway, he was like really, really nice, like to the point
where he was like, oh yeah, so yeah, like what are you doing
in Japan?
And I was like, oh yeah, yeah, just like do my best, be
like, you know, yeah, I was a singer and stuff.
And then he was like, mutual respect is what he said to me.
Yeah, and then he said my favorite shadow line as well.
Yeah, it was amazing.
I had a great time.
Also, I had a great time meeting you guys.
Try to imitate it.
The line.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, no.
Did you record it?
If the world becomes my enemy, I will fight like I always
have.
I can't be edgy.
I love Latinos.
I mean, I could have asked for that line.
Oh, it was so great.
enjoyed it very much and then yeah i've been i i i've either
created the best or the worst thing ever by combining a very
typical british dish which is like this the cremas the
cremas leftovers it's called bubble and squeak you guys have
ever heard of bubble bubble and squeak yeah bubble and
squeak it's like that's so cute you mash up all of the roast
potatoes the vegetables and stuff and then you make a
pancake out of it Anyway, I made the pancake and I was like
frying the pancake and I was like, this looks like
something.
This looks like Okonomiyaki.
And I was like, what if I put Okonomiyaki sauce and Kupi
mayonnaise on it?
And it was one of those moments I was like, big brain, all
the equations, the meme.
And I was like, wow, I've created something truly innovative
here.
So I'll have to make it.
It was so peem.
so oh my god wait that reminds me vicky when i i went to
disney after holiday matzari oh yeah i was i was at epcot
and um our group of friends we were really hungry and like
all the restaurants were booked for a long time except the
british food and so we went to epcot to eat british food
But everyone else got the bangers and mash.
Bangers and mash.
Oh.
I love what that says about British cuisine, though.
Cues for everything apart from the British restaurant.
Yeah, but it's awesome because we were able to eat.
I mean, what did you think of it?
Did you think it was nice or were you just happy to eat
something?
Yeah.
Actually, everybody who got the bangers and mash, we're
like, this is really good.
Oh, wait, what is a banger?
A banger?
Something mashed is mashed potatoes?
Yeah.
A banger is a sausage.
So it's like sausage mash and a ton of gravy.
Hopefully they had a ton of gravy.
I hardly even know her.
Oh, that actually worked.
It worked.
Do you guys say a bang as a slang?
No?
You don't?
Maybe that's why?
Is that kind of why?
Okay, we learned something today, chat.
We learned something today.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
British people in the chat right now.
That was so tough.
Well, well, we've learned something.
Lessons from Santa.
Lessons from, from, yeah, sure, from Santa.
Yep.
Anyways, guys, do you want to hear a little bit about what
we're doing today for our festive, festive times?
Are you excited?
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
So we are doing...
Marshmallow Advent!
Yes.
We have 24 days leading up to a Christmas.
surprise from from yours truly um but leading up to that day
of the 25th and the surprise that i've waiting for you guys
we have a little marshmallow advent to do so because you
know we did we did the game before and we did what how many
questions not very many i don't remember at all yeah i feel
like we were we were yapping a lot so i figured you know why
why not why not do more marshmallows so that's what we're
doing
okay are you guys actually what is the best way to do this
can you guys see the stream is that fine it's a little
delayed but I think it's okay I'll read the question as well
so choto a minute choto a minute let's get the first advent
you guys ready to open and open your advent calendar?
Yeah.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Here we go.
You ready?
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
Number one.
Group question.
From each of you regarding the other two.
What is a song you'd like to hear them perform?
This could be individually or as a duet.
Ooh.
Oh, like each person, not as a group.
i think it's like each person like what do you want to hear
them sing oh that's hard
okay i think i can go okay so i was thinking with i want to
be honeybee i was thinking how much like some some some
classic kiari pamu pamu would suit phoebe i want to hear you
sing some like yeah i don't know some of some of my favorite
kiari tunes i think now really cute and you could do the
dance as well.
What's a favorite Kiari tune?
Yeah, what is your favorite?
Oh, that's so hard.
I like that one.
I think it would sound cute.
And for Minto, I want to hear you sing some like some James
Bond, some the world is not enough.
Like some very like jazzy like Like, mmm, damn, kind of bond
tunes.
I think that would be pretty cool.
Try it.
I'll try it.
What about you guys?
I'm, like, digging into my brain of music.
Because, like, my...
Go ahead.
I'm too Macross-pilled.
I'm trying to think of things that aren't Macross right now.
I was literally...
Oh, my gosh.
I was like, I want to hear Phoebe sing Macross.
I was like, but that's because you already sing it.
And so I'm like, I said, I'm like, oh, yeah, we're macros.
I mean, there's a lot of macros songs, though.
So, specifically, you could say a specific song for macros.
I will sing it, probably.
Wait, oh, oh, gosh, what's that?
Digging into the internal jukebox, like, oh, what was that?
What was that song?
I think Phoebe's voice would suit Okazan.
Okazaki Ritzko's like songs really well like fruits basket.
Okazaki Ritzko stuff.
Yeah, I think your voice suits that, you know, like, oh my
gosh, the Princess Tutu opening and stuff like that.
Oh my gosh, I love, I love that.
There's an ending, there's an ending song to Princess Tutu
that's by Okazaki Ritzko.
And I do a strange dance to it whenever I hear it.
I get on the ground.
I want to see this.
Oh.
Yeah.
And I worm on the ground.
I don't know why.
But my...
Can you imagine it?
Just imagine a shrimp on the ground.
Like you're doing the worm or you're kind of squirming.
You're squirming.
Just on its side.
Imagine a shrimp on its side on the ground.
And then it's just kind of like contracting and
uncontracting.
Do you know just like...
I don't know.
Yeah.
Is this the dance movie you bring out at the Christmas
parties?
Specifically only for the ending song The Princess Tutu.
So this is something you've been doing.
Is this like...
Like...
It is!
I started listening, I started watching Princess Tutu
finally because I read the manga as a kid.
And then I was like, ooh, I'm feeling, I'm feeling on the
beat for this.
It's just a little, it's a slight little bossa nova kind of
beat.
It's really sweet, it's really cute.
I started shrimping on the ground.
like squirming on the ground and I was like this is my dance
for this specific song now it's like a it's like a physical
stimming like it is a fascinating party trick I want to see
it imagine it in 3d like 3d concert so you say you do this
regularly like how many times a week would you say how many
episodes of
Look at penis position, yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait, so this is a new recent, like, kind of, because
you said you just, like, started.
No, no, when I watched Princess Tutu, like, maybe, like,
three, two, three years ago for the first time, I don't skip
the opening or the ending song for anime when I watch it.
I don't.
So every time I got to the ending of an episode, and the
song came on, I started really feeling it, and so I just
shrimped on the ground.
She could get unlocked.
Phoebe, does anyone know this?
Is this, like, the first time you're explaining this to
anybody?
This is the first time I'm ever telling this story.
I'm sure.
So every 23 minutes or so, if you're binging, yeah, exactly.
I was binging.
Phoebe, can you make a promise to us when, when, if in the
future we ever get to do something in 3D, can you teach us?
Oh, yeah.
I can.
You know what it reminds me of in terms of Chica Gay and
stuff?
Is it like Gundam Epion?
Just a little bit.
It's like, it's a little bit like that.
Okay, I think I get it.
Yeah, you kind of get, but like, but like on your side, on
the floor.
Okay, I get it, I get it.
I don't, the thing is, is I don't remember the ending.
I remember the opening song, but I don't remember the ending
song at all.
So I can't imagine the song at all for YouTube.
That's a...
Yeah, I mean...
I'll link it so you guys can listen to it later on.
It's not the kind of song that...
You're gonna be like, what?
You were shrimpin' on the ground to this song?
I'm listening to it right now.
I'm gonna listen to it right now.
I'm very intrigued to listen to it after this.
Yes.
Well, okay, Walla!
Anyway, the songs I think you guys should sing?
Or Vince didn't get to say what song she thinks Vicky should
sing.
Oh, sorry.
For Vicky, I want to hear either The Beatles because I think
it would be really cute because you're both British.
But also, Evanescence.
I love Evanescence!
Wait, Minko, will you do, though?
Wake me up!
for me oh yeah i'll do i'll do it for you i'll do it wake me
up wake me up you could you could both do that wake me up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so good i'm excited i love the
beatles my my dad my dad would always play the beatles so i
grew up on the beatles yeah so i can i can sing any beatles
for you yeah oh that'd be wonderful You know what, that's a,
that's a, I can hear Vicky's voice singing the Beatles.
Yeah, yeah, right, right.
Ah, thanks, guys.
What about you, Febe?
I think, okay, I'm gonna, I'm gonna think duets this time,
because there are so many songs that I've been wanting to
sing with you guys, trills and duets.
But like, with Vicky, I would really like to duet a, like,
Takarazuka-style song together.
I'm so down.
Because I know we both really like the Takoratsuka Theater.
And also, like, the way that we split songs already between
the three of us is, like, Vicky does the alto part.
And then I do the first soprano part.
So it feels very, like...
Yeah!
Like we could do a lot of, like, high-low duets together.
So, like, kind of, like, review Starlight stuff.
yeah that'd be so good or any any of the takorazuka songs
when it's like the the main male and female parts do the
duet together you know romantic duet we could definitely do
those yeah i would love to that sounds so nice and then with
uh with mint oh god there's also a lot of songs that i
wanted to do together as well but um i i feel like Because
we both, like, grew up liking Macross Frontier a lot.
So, definitely some Macross songs together, I think.
I mean, with both of you, too.
Because I ended up going to a Macross concert with Vicky
earlier this year as well.
And I feel like there's a lot of Macross duets and group
songs that we could do together.
But also, like, jazz stuff.
We really like jazz.
I'm trying to think of...
trying to think of like jazzy duets or we could just do
class like classic things like a magnet or something not the
magnet i would still do harmonies yeah pull out pull out the
magnet i don't think i've heard a serious magnet cover in a
very very very long time yeah it's kind of got a reputation
now wait vicky how'd you get my i don't know why do i have
your can i is this something i can fix wait wait hold on let
me try it wait it took too much and then it stuck it got
sticky Oh, oh, oh, oh, I see it.
You can put, yeah.
Oh, it's got sticky.
I'm so sorry.
Why is it floating?
What is it floating?
Now you're eating it.
I took it.
All right.
Anyway, carry on.
I got distracted.
Okay.
Well, that's nice.
Maybe it's cold outside.
We got a...
Baby, it's cold outside.
Oh, you ready for question two?
Yeah.
Day two of the Advent.
Minto question.
If you had a collab meal with McDonald's, what would it
have?
Collab meal with McDonald's.
Well, I would think.
I think I would make it my...
The only thing that I order at McDonald's if I ever go
with ketchup and pickle and that's that's what it would be I
mean that sounds good only has ketchup and pickle on top of
the meat only ketchup and pickle wait that's your normal
order yep not even the free smile there's a free smile yeah
you can order a smile that's still a thing at least you used
to be able to order a smile yeah what yeah be like i demand
that you smile at me right now i can give i imagine them
like browning and then giving you a little like a yes like a
quick one yeah what if i order 10 smiles like not in america
oh is that is that a uk thing that's dystopian oh and you
guys only Oh, they're on there.
That's where I heard it from.
Okay, my collab would be only smiles.
Only smiles.
And it's not free.
Oh, I like that.
Yeah.
I mean, I'd still order it.
Hopefully you're not hungry though.
If it came with some like, I don't know, Minto toy, I'd
still, I'd still pay for all smiles.
why not yeah a little squeezy toy or so yeah all right
question three group if nvp ended up on stranded on a
deserted island who would resort to cannibalism first
i don't want to alarm you guys i've been playing a lot of
games with cannibalism in it lately so really my brain i'm
not i'm not opposed to the idea because i'm desensitized
oh defining as cannibalism like a cheeky finger a cheeky
finger what about a cheeky cheek a cheeky i bet the rough is
really delicious no i mean there's meat on my rump for days
if we need I will give up my rump if you have just a little
bit of it it'll grow back surely you know it'll scab over
and grow back I'm sure it'd be fine I think that would be
fine if it's for you guys to survive I will give up my cake
for you guys oh I will have a flat cake for the rest of my
life to feed you guys okay so we will always survive three
cakes isn't that crazy three cakes wait you can have your
cake and eat it too yeah that didn't answer the question
though who would resort to it first oh who would actually
eat the said thing i feel like i feel like we would all want
okay correct me if i'm wrong if it was me i would want us
all to survive so i'd be willing to share some fingers or a
cheeky cheek with you guys.
I definitely think fingers should be like the last to go.
Oh, really?
Because they're important.
Yeah, you need them for gripping.
Oh, yeah, it's true.
What kind of need you don't use?
It's probably fine.
Do you need toes?
We need those for gripping too.
Do you do?
Do you?
I grip with my toes.
Oh, yeah, we had this call conversation before the show yeah
we talked about this before
all right i think maybe your your i don't know maybe the
cake is the least important part maybe i mean what what are
you using it for other than to twerk i mean it would be sad
not to twerk anymore but i think i could deal with it you
know that's that's her favorite activity vicky roman i don't
know how to out of the club, twerking it away.
Anyway, I think, who would add, right, I think based on what
Minto said, maybe Minto would do it first.
I think so.
Probably.
I think it would be a great opportunity for me to have an
excuse to try.
Okay!
I guess you're, like, bacon.
Anyway, go ahead.
Question four.
Four.
What have we got?
Phoebe.
All right.
Right, now that she's next to you, how do you feel about
mint-flavored foods?
Now that she's next to me...
Oh, cannibalism...
Wait, maybe Phoebe's the first one to cannibalize.
Yeah, maybe!
Maybe!
Oh, look, think about this, though.
Your hands were in front of my face earlier, and I went for
the candy cane instead.
Oh, that's so rude.
That's true, that's true.
I could have...
I could have done a little bit of finger-sucking, but I did
not.
I... I... You know, I just ate the candy cane.
candy can like a normal, non-cannibal human being.
Baby, baby, not on stream.
Yeah.
I can't know.
You can't do that.
No, no, no.
No, no.
Yeah, right.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Mint flavored foods.
Oh, good.
Oh, we had a, we had a whole incident earlier today where my
housemate made chocolate cookies but didn't tell anybody she
put peppermint in it.
Oh, and, uh, what happened?
Well, people complained, and then I ended up eating all the
cookies.
So, I guess I'm, you know what, I, I'm almost more inclined
to eat mint flavored foods because then I miss her.
And then it feels like she's, you know, it feels like she's,
she's with me.
You're part of me?
I don't know which, but you eat me, I'm gone.
And then this like absence makes the heart grow fonder.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And then eat mint foods again.
And then it's a endless cycle.
Yeah.
And the cycle.
And it makes you feel like your breath is fresh even when
it's not, you know?
I'm in your heart as me and as the cholesterol.
And as the cholesterol.
How romantic.
So, yes, I almost like them more now because of her.
Ah.
So that means you didn't like it originally.
Is that what you're saying?
Stir in the pot.
I so like.
I also...
So, when it came to...
No, I didn't like a lot of mint-flavored food, actually.
But when it came to mint chocolate chip ice cream, I like
the burn of the mint with the crunchiness of the chocolate
chip.
You know, it's the perfect flavor for it.
You just want to feel something.
Yeah, no, you just want to feel something.
So true.
Oh, my gosh.
People make fun of me, but I like to have a...
When I have a mask on, I like to eat a cough drop.
And then I like to have the burn of the cough drop go into
my eyes.
you really feel something.
Wait, that's not a big brain.
I'm going to try that next time.
Really?
Yeah, yeah.
It's like just really feels like something.
Sometimes you just want to feel something.
Is it like extra effective as well?
Because it's entering via your throat and via your eyes at
the same time.
Maybe.
Maybe that's why it feels good.
I'm going to have to try it, I think.
Question 5.
My suggestion for everybody.
5.
Do it.
Five.
Here we go.
Question 5.
of the advent.
Hi Densetsu, for the ultimate vibe test.
I was wondering, what's your boba orders?
Oh.
Okay, first question.
Do you guys actually drink boba on a regular basis?
I do.
Okay.
Yes.
Do you?
Very occasionally, I'll be honest.
Not super often.
I'm actually not that big on tapioca.
I know a lot of people like that.
though yeah i love them balls that's okay though did i fail
vibe check chat now for me i like i like the fruity popping
things like fruity popping light yeah i don't know any of
that kind of thing yeah it does count it counts yeah and
some black tea lovely what about you guys so i have like a
local place yeah i have a local place so i can't they have
like a special order that i get so i can't say but but if i
go it depends i have two orders if i'm in a fruity mood i
like anything like a raspberry kind of tea or something i'll
get that and if i'm in a milky mood i'll get anything that's
like an oreo oh that sounds so good
i uh i'm very basic i like brown sugar boba milk tea like
honestly kind of like vicky i don't I don't care too much
for Boba.
Like, Boba pearls themselves.
Like, I'll have them if they're there.
But what I really like is a good tea.
So if the tea is yummy, then that's what matters to me.
And then if they have, like, a cream.
Because, like, in California, we have, like, a chain called
Happy Lemon.
And they have, like, a puff cream.
It's just, like, a super-y-y cream kind of thing.
I like getting cream on that.
Just sugar and cream.
I'm, like, it's, like, a child's order.
But that's what I like, basically.
the boba in it usually because it's like slightly sweetened
and so i'll get my tea zero percent or 25 percent sugar and
then the boba sweetens the rest so it's pretty nice oh
you're so adult you're so grown up about it am i like you
want reduced they're like we recommend the reduced 80
percent sugar and i'm like give me the full sugar give it to
me no i'm with mint though in this one i don't i don't like
tea that's too sugary well it's like with regular tea as
well i don't put sugar in Me too, yeah.
And a bit of milk, that's all you need, you know what I'm
saying?
I agree.
Do you have sugar in normal tea, Phoebe, like, in a black
tea, hot black tea?
Do you have sugar in there?
I put, well, I have a lot of honey in my teas just because
it's good for your guilt.
No, honey.
But yeah, I will, during my barista arc, I did put lots of
cream and sugar in my hot drinks.
Oh.
A long drink.
You don't need any more sweetness because you're already
plenty sweet.
Yeah.
Mew.
Question six.
Vicky, you are so productive and on that grind set
constantly, what are your top tips to stay focused and...
What are you saying?
Okay, this is something very specific to me, and I know you
guys might have an opinion.
I cannot stand the word EP.
Oh, yeah.
Listen, just say sleepy.
Why do you need to take the letters of the word?
I thought you were complimenting me, whoever sent this in.
Clearly, you're trying to get me to say the word that I
hate.
She got rage-bidden, Phoebe.
She got rage-bidden.
Oh, no.
Oh, she got one guy.
Oh, one guy.
Oh, no.
one feel the same as me does no one share my passion my
passionate hatred no vicky has given me the ep pass before
because i don't actually use the word ep phoebe like said it
to me like in person i think and i was like okay you're
you're cute phoebe so i forgive you it's fine it's like it's
like if a if a cute tiny bunny said i'm ep then i'd be like
okay you're cute and sweet so i forget You know, that's how
I feel when Phoebe says Eepie is okay.
Oh, oh, I'm glad.
I'm Eepie.
Do I get the pass?
If Santa came down my chimney, took his cookie and said, I'm
Eepie, then I'd kick his butt straight back out of the
chimney.
Absolutely.
not right next question seven question seven group can you
try to say oh god I wish to wash my iris no no no this is
evil this is evil okay should we take it in turns who wants
to go first I am waiting for it to change on my stream okay
I refuse.
I've played these games before.
It's Min's turn to be rage baited.
When I first debuted, I did like a...
I would also put out small videos.
I did only just a couple of them.
But one of them was doing tongue twisters.
And this one.
This one is just so evil.
It's so...
I'm guessing you don't want to go first then I will I will
attempt I will attempt okay okay I wish to wash my Irish
wristwatch I wish to wash my Irish wristwatch I wish to wash
my Irish wristwatch I wish to wash my Irish wristwatch I
wish to wash my Irish wristwatch oh wow the five times
that's five times it's five times okay what I will say I
feel like I do have a knack for these just send me them in
the chat and i i i i try my best to do them all right phoebe
go for it i think minto's got some like trauma for this one
oh my god i'm processing i'm just loading right now i also
like doing these but it doesn't mean i'm good at it so let
me try you got this i wish to wash my irish wrist watch i
wish to wash my irish wrist watch I wish to watch my Irish
It was okay at first I wish to watch my Irish wristwatch I
should be doing better I'm a voice actor I should be better
I wish to watch Have you guys seen that like Trend on TikTok
right now That's like say the things on the beat Yeah I want
to do it now I want to do it too Oh my god next collab guys
Next collab should we do it Yes I want to do it so bad I
don't think I've seen this But But it sounds fun.
Sounds like you guys really want to do it.
The one guy with the inflatable hammer who's like taking it
way too seriously.
Is that the one you're talking about?
So good.
They're so funny.
Yeah, they're so good.
Anyway, enough about TikTok.
Minto, go ahead.
Avoiding.
I wish to watch my Irish wristwatch.
to rush my irish wish wrist watch honestly that was pretty
good i think you i think you do better than phoebe i'm gonna
be honest sorry phoebe no way no i'm not even gonna deny it
i'm i'm impressed i'm impressed uh you guys don't have to
say that see practice practice makes perfect i guess it was
fueled by pure spite yeah yeah yeah I need to be more
spiteful And then my wrist watching Will be more Irish Yeah
Exactly Alright question 8 Da da da da da da da Da da da da
Mint quick Revolver Ocelot comes out of a portal Oh dear And
offers to take you back with him to I don't want to butcher
that pronunciation Wait I'll see it in a second Once I
update T-S-T-L-I-N-O.
C-L-N-R-C-L-C-S.
Do you offer?
You have five seconds.
The portal's closing.
Mint, the portal's closing.
I go, I go.
Oh, yes, yes, 100 times yes.
Thank you guys so much for supporting Densetsu.exe.
It was fun while it lasted for a good month.
Oh, happy one month, by the way.
Oh my gosh, yay!
right men got taken away to selenoyarsk selenoyarsk
selenoyarsk i mean if we go too if we jump in the portal
then then it's fine right oh it's so true bye you guys den
set who lives on but not not for you yeah that means we
would be going like back in time we'd be like in the 60s or
something so like we could be the first vtubers for real
real oh my god you're so right big brain Oh, wow.
But what is waiting for us?
There's some, from what I've heard, some Snake X Ocelot is
waiting.
No?
Is that waiting for us, Minto?
Yep.
Is that waiting?
Probably.
Yeah, probably.
Okay.
Well, looking forward to that.
Yeah, you'd be in the Russian jungles, so.
Oh.
Yeah, the jungles of Russia, the famous jungles that...
are totally there in Russia.
Wait, is this snake eater or is this different?
No.
Yes?
Yeah, this is snake eater.
Oh, snake eater.
Okay, I've seen some different plants.
I've seen the crocodiles.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Russian crocodiles.
The Russia.
That's where they totally live.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Question nine.
Da-da-da-da-da.
Aw.
Question from Stuffs.
And name three qualities you like.
about each other.
Aww.
That's so sweet.
Okay.
I think we just, if we spend too long thinking about it,
we'll be here ages because I'm sure there's lots of things
that we want to say to each other.
But I'm just gonna go ahead and do it.
Okay, Minto.
I'm just gonna say what comes to my head.
Minto, I love how you're so passionate about your hobbies
and that you will do anything and go anywhere for the things
that you love.
I love that about you.
Yeah, I love that about you.
Phoebe, I love that you're genuinely so kind to everyone and
just such a pure, beautiful soul.
I think that's very sweet.
Yeah, all right, you guys say some things.
Well, I think some more.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You, you work so hard.
this applies to like this group in general but you work so
hard and you've never ever given up on your dreams you've
always found a way forward and i think that despite all
everything you've managed to still not just give up on your
dreams but you haven't given up on being a good person too
all the while oh that's something truly beautiful about you
i think that's the thing about like all of us really i think
that's the basis of gen zetsu right yeah i think so i think
so It's kind of the uniting thing.
Yeah, I think so.
And also that we're big fat nerds.
I love that you guys are nerds.
No, but I love that.
I do like that.
I do love that we all have our very specific interests and
we're all like very fun together.
We all like to joke and we have good humor together.
I love that about us.
so i feel like we're all like different flavors of nerd you
know what i mean yeah like how we come together in this
beautiful casserole of nerdiness okay oh yeah another thing
okay so this is phoebe and then i'll say another minto one i
love how you're so considerate like like when you had this
when i took you to the eye hospital and you didn't want to
wake me up so you didn't wake me up even though you needed
to go to the eye hospital and i was like why don't you wake
me up you
can go when you're feeling energized wake me up wake me up
inside evanescence evanescence can't wake up and then meet
me at the eye hospital yeah me i'm like we need to go right
now yeah yeah yeah kukiyomi yeah i i i absolutely have no
kukiyomi whatsoever so it's good that someone does in this
group yeah and me though i i i love i i love that you're so
also so kind and considerate but i also love your yapping
sessions i love tuning in to your streams when you're like
when i when you were doing your japan recap i was having so
much fun just like sitting there with a cuppa listening to i
feel like you've got such a great way of like telling things
like not storytelling because it's stuff that actually
happened but like you know i mean the way you tell stuff is
like so intriguing it just makes me want to watch you
forever so really i always thought that was like my weak
point no i'm not good at it for sure yeah yeah i feel like
i'm gonna repeat so much about already like you know
probably one of the kindest people I've ever met ever like
you you are literal angel like if you know I mentioned
fruits basket earlier because like you are so you are like
Toru Honda like just an angel you know you're so so kind and
so sweet and so you know you're just a little I gotta hold
you in my hands and protect you and then you know Vicky you
are you are so strong and you're so and you're so smart like
you you are so talented and that you know how to do
everything she's like multi-multi yeah it's insane ah you
guys i mean you guys do i feel like we have so many like
cool skills that come together you know so i'm so meant your
your spirit is so free i don't know how to like explaining
any other way.
Yes!
I know what I mean, right Vicky?
I am free!
No, it's like, I want to, I want to live like that because I
think that is the most, like, that is the most satisfying
and happy and like human way of living is just to have such
a free spirit and to just let your, let your love and your
passion and your feelings run wild.
And that's how you're able to do stuff like, like your, like
your lore video during your debut recently with the, with
the freaking.
Kiku on.
And it's all these creative ideas that spawn in your brain.
And all of the silly little moments, too.
Like, it's pain.
You know?
Spawns from your spirit being free.
I don't know if that's what that was.
I think it is.
No, it is.
I think I'm just stupid.
No, no, no, no.
I know exactly what Phoebe means.
It's hard to explain in words, but you have that kind of,
yeah, Like, that's just, that's Minto, you know?
You've got that beautiful shining spirit.
Unapologetically you.
Yeah.
I don't know how to be anybody else.
I love it.
I love that.
Oh, you guys.
I love you guys.
I think we had a shared thing as well, so that's probably
around three.
I feel like we all feel warm and fuzzy inside, so.
There's more we could say, but we would yet forever on one
question.
Yeah.
And we're on the question 10 Over the calendar, guys
Do-do-do-do-do Do-do-do-do Group.
Who's the mommy?
Who's the dad?
Very different energy This question.
Who's the mommy?
Who's the daddy?
Who's the baby?
Well, I think we know who the baby is
Who pray tell?
No, Phoebe baby.
Phoebe baby.
I don't know.
I have a beard on, so I think maybe Maybe you're the daddy.
I'm the mommy.
Actually, I think mental...
I think this is pretty accurate.
I think mental is daddy.
Yeah, I think...
To be honest, I think probably that is true.
And then I'm the... I'm the mom, I guess.
Yeah.
You have very nurturing vibes.
Yeah, you do, yeah.
And the one who's, like...
The one who's actually, like, on top of doing all, like, the
taxes and the, like, account...
The bookkeeping and stuff behind the scenes.
And then there's daddy.
Daddy goes and it goes to work and I do actually file my own
taxes LaMau no way I file them too but I don't know if I do
them the right way or not no you do Phoebe say you do I'm
sure you do Phoebe you do I do I do them correctly I do I do
them correctly I do baby baby baby no you do it just fine
don't worry baby it's okay baby no tax those taxes for sure
yeah that was surprisingly easy to i think so actually yeah
i think so all right then straight to question 11.
11.
phoebe this question for phoebe i just wanted to say i'm so
so excited for you i've been following your journey as an
idol and to see you blossom in this group with two amazing
partners in crime is truly beautiful sorry that's not a
question i wanted to ask what you're most excited to do with
mint and vicky oh very sweet most excited well first of all
that's very very sweet thank you i want to blossom more and
make everyone proud you guys and also mint and vicky i want
to make everyone proud but also what i'm most excited i mean
there's That's hard because there's a lot of things to be
excited about.
But I think I've personally always really, really enjoyed
making original music.
That's like one of my favorite parts of doing music stuff
and idol stuff.
And I feel like there's a lot of things that I've always
wanted to say personally via my music.
But what about the things that the three of us can say
together?
The experiences that we have shared, the experiences that we
all relate to.
and the things that we want to convey to you guys.
So I'm excited to see what kind of music is born from it.
I mean, like, Densetsu MVPs was really awesome.
We also made that in, like, two weeks.
So, like, what are we going to also be made?
Anita's not crazy, bro.
Oh, my God.
I know.
Absolutely.
So amazing.
Yeah.
Given more time to cook in the kitchen, though, I wonder
what kinds of, like, crazy stuff we'll come up with and what
kinds of feelings we'll want to put into our music.
So that probably is what I'm most excited for.
I'm so excited for that too!
Me too!
I'm excited to do the shrimp.
I'm excited to be taught the shrimp dance by Phoebe in 3D.
I gotta learn.
In 3D.
We're gonna have to get a top down camera.
The camera's not the pan to the top and it's gonna show us
wiggling on the grass.
You know how like sometimes like people with like when they
do 3D streams, when they're like transitioning, they have
like an eye catch or something that's like loading.
all of us like kind of in a circle like on the ground doing
the shrimp it's gonna be some kind it's gonna look like some
kind of demonic ritual but I promise it's very fun and cute
yes it's gonna be so good yes all right question 12 do do do
do do do group did you know each other before the dead and
said to project if not how did you react to vicky being
british what do you mean how did you react to being british
huh what do you mean honestly it was like kind of a crazy
shock it was like i've never met a british person before and
so i i just didn't expect her to be british i just i thought
i thought there were only myths and fairy tales and so on
Well, for me, I had Steiner as a manager for a long while.
But then when I met Vicky, I was like, Oh my God, there's
more of this.
Right.
Yep.
Yeah.
And then she just started saying things like Kappa.
And...
I feel really honored that the Queen's people is...
Sorry.
Yeah.
We have royalty.
We're learning so much like cultural exchange.
Yeah, royalty in our group.
Yeah.
Exactly.
What a queen.
Thanks.
Thanks, guys.
Well, I mean, the good thing about the answers is that they
were positive.
They didn't say anything negative.
So that's good, right, chat?
Yeah.
You know, thinking British people are myths.
There's only like, I don't know, five of them or something.
I mean, like unicorns are like that too, right?
I love cryptids.
Yeah.
British people.
The, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool.
We're just, we're just made up myths that don't exist.
That's what people think of me.
I've seen this in Harry Potter before.
Isn't that creepy?
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa.
They're real.
I thought it was just Hollywood special effects that they
put a filter on their voice.
Yeah, guys, I'm sorry, I'm going to turn the filter off now.
To the true Vicky Roman, this is the real one.
I'm going to have some sweet tea on the sweet Christmas.
Oh, my dream.
My dream's crushed.
Oh, no.
I'm so sorry.
I've been using a voice filler up until now.
Oh, my gosh.
I had my suspicions.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, you know, we've got to guess.
some barbecue now that I've got my true voice back.
Barbecue.
Wait, what accent are you trying to...
Right, anyway, let's expeliamus into the next question,
shall we?
13!
Vicky, if...
Oh my...
What are all these cursed questions for me?
If Vicky and Mint were dangling over a lava-filled volcano,
and the villain who captured them said, a durian and i'll
free them what would you do what right can i give some
context okay can i give some context genuinely okay i i've
had fresh durian okay i had some fresh stuff recently in
thailand i literally thought i was gonna vomit in the middle
of the in the middle of the food market guys okay like i
cannot stand the stuff However, however, okay, I would first
try and make a deal with the villain.
You know, there's got to be some movement here.
There's got to be something else.
Can I point out a flaw in this plan?
What?
I would like to say, I'm, well, I'm already dead.
So, you know, I'm a lost cause.
Oh, yeah.
Phoebe has wings.
She's a very strong.
Get played, villain.
Get played.
Yeah, that's so true.
It's like in Sonic Adventure.
too where like rouge is falling towards the lava and it's
like bro you're a bat it's that's like with vicky exactly so
i don't even need to eat the durian oh big brain minter
thank you for saving me you saved my life you saved my life
right vicky was the one who got saved instead it was my life
you can't fly right um i mean i i oh okay we won't know till
we try the wings are there I think...
It's like throwing a baby in a pool, right?
That's how they learn to swim.
Yeah, yeah, it's like the baby's naturally know how to swim,
right?
It'll be the same.
Yeah, you're dropping towards my death, towards lava.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And surely my wings will start to flap and fly, fly, fly,
you know.
You know, what kind of parents are me and Minto if we don't
let our baby have these experiences?
I vote a bet.
Let's push you from the nest into the lava.
I'm so glad that my mother and father care about my
education so much.
I'm so glad.
It's decided then.
I'm not eating the derby.
Question 14.
Oof.
Would you rather fight?
Okay, I guess chat can answer as well for this one.
Would you rather fight a hundred mint-sized Phoebe's or one
Phoebe-sized mint?
It's the question.
We're almost the same height.
Yeah.
We're the same height.
I guess the person who sent this in must think that Min is
much more threatening, I suppose.
Which staff San sent this in?
This is a staff question?
Yeah!
Um...
What are you implying, staff San?
Yeah!
What are you saying, staff San?
Um, I feel like this would have made more sense with, like,
me and you guys, because...
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, I would...
I think I could...
I think I could take either of you come at me, so I would
rather fight one of you.
So I'll go for the Phoebe-sized min-tho, I guess.
And that means I have to fight!
I'm sorry, Santa.
Put him up, Santa.
I think Santa's ripped, though.
He probably has, like, super arms carrying all of his...
Yeah, probably.
Actually, yeah.
taller than you so you just grow and you grow a centimeter
so you're actually getting buffed you're getting one
centimeter by one centimeter one centimeter buff yeah makes
all the difference the surreal deep question is it all right
well chat what would you do i feel like a lot of chat
They're saying a hundred, a hundred Phoebe's.
What?
You scared, Jack.
You scared her.
The Phoebe size mint.
You scared of ripped Santa.
Okay.
Ho, ho, ho.
Oh, I'm scared of ripped Santa.
All right.
Fifteen.
Do, do, do, do, do.
Mint, if you had to wear either Vicky or Phoebe's outfit,
which would you like?
What would you choose and why?
Ooh, interesting.
What?
Wait, oh my gosh, that's so difficult.
Um, on the one hand, um, I think, like, Vicky, I would want
to wear yours because I'm used to wearing a uniform.
Like, I'm in my main outfit all the time.
Makes sense, makes sense.
It, I feel like it would be, like, uncomfortable for me.
Maybe the chest area would be a little, I would need to...
It probably is a little...
Saggy was what I was getting.
Is that what I was going to say?
But at the same time, Phoebe, your outfit is so breezy and
I'm also used to my pits being out all the time.
So...
Yeah.
I think I would be comfortable in that one too.
We're on different reasons.
What are you guys saying?
I think you would fit, Minto, just fine.
Stop that.
No, it would be it would fit just fine.
What are you saying?
They're honest.
Chat, please.
You can fit more things.
You can fit things in there, you know, store stuff.
Oh!
Yeah!
You go win some plushies at the arcade and you shove them in
there.
There's more carrying space.
I've seen people do that.
They'll like, they'll carry a little plushie and then
they'll pull it out when they're trying to diffuse the
argument.
What?
Because they're like, you gotta talk like that to him?
Oh, that is so real.
I'm gonna keep that in mind.
That's the best kind of defense.
Yeah, two eye blues could fit in there.
I could just, I could be like a little, uh, a double-decker
bus, you know?
Is that how we stop ourselves from, um, what?
Shove me in there and then pull me out and be like, you're
gonna say that to him?
You're gonna say that to this guy?
Whenever there is a Phoebe and Vicky plushies, then you guys
get, everybody here can get them and then do that.
Carry everybody around.
You get into an argument with somebody, pull little Phoebe.
I'd be like, you're going to say that to her.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, that could work.
You got to make marketable plushies, yep.
I was going to say that we could use that technique, you
know, Mommy and daddy, Mint and Mint and Vicky so we don't
fight in front of the baby, you know, so we don't fight in
front of baby Phoebe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys both have PB plushies in your chest and you both
have them both out at the same time.
You're going to say that to me.
You're going to say that to our baby.
Oh my god.
Good, good, good.
And with that, question 16.
how many there's 25 days oh my gosh we're over halfway yeah
and then there's something special waiting for you guys day
25 something very special very special indeed uh main vicky
would you love us if we were a worm and specifically for
phoebe would you love us if we were a white pickman i don't
have the context for this if you got something against these
pickmen a white pickman yeah what is yeah okay he's just a
little bit he's just kind of an asshole just a little bit
but but i but i i love him anyway though every pickman is a
good pickman he's just got he needs he needs some therapy
but you know it's i can fix him i so i would love yes i
would love you if you were a white pick well but you guys
would you love them if they were a worm yeah sure why not
you know like it might be hard to tie as long as you guys
are willing to put in the effort to keep typing in chat with
your little your little worm tail true yeah if you're gonna
still be like woohoo or barkers yeah then sure yeah worms i
don't i don't mind you come on in yeah what about you
imagine them like hastily like flipping around on the
keyboard yeah
i i would hope it's a gummy worm so i could go
um that's chat that's chat you're talking about you're just
you're just gonna that you're just gonna that's for some
people that's their dream you know that's not true i won't
deny someone their goal in life yeah of being slurped up as
a worm i just like gummy worms
I'm intrigued.
The twin snakes, have you guys ever heard of those?
They're so good.
Wait, what?
Yeah, that sounds like an intense...
Dummy worm twins?
And it's also a Metal Gear reference, so they're even
better.
Really?
Oh!
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
I see it.
Yeah.
Oh, they're sweet and sour.
Not the pole.
The power being lost.
into the main account.
I'm gonna say, heck yeah.
What do you say, chat?
With that, let's go to question 17.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Phoebe, pineapple pizza.
Yes or no?
Follow up the question.
What pizza topping would you order?
the other girls dozo oh well um actually i do like pineapple
pizza i am you know what i'm yippee i'm not i'm not budging
on this you guys have to love me and accept me for who i am
and and this is what i am right now is a a filthy pineapple
pizza enjoyer that's me wait i think we've just realized
something important we're all pineapple pizza people are we
yeah Yeah!
You have to love us for who we are.
Honestly, I'm going to be, I'm going to say something maybe
controversial.
I think most people are pineapple pizza enjoyers, but
they're afraid of the stigma.
You know what?
I think they want to be, some people just want to be haters
too.
I think so.
They just want to be, they want to, they think they're too
cool to like pineapple pizza.
Yeah, they want to be different.
I was hanging out with some friends and we got pineapple
pizza and, and most people ate the pineapple pizza and not
the cheese or the, or the other one.
I don't remember what this is.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I bet they, some people snuck it.
They were like, they're looking around like, is anybody,
anybody watching?
Yeah.
My reputation.
I must be sneaky about this.
Yeah, they probably just, they probably just want to be
edgy, like, no, I can't be seen eating pineapple pizza.
No.
I'm so cool.
My friends will reject me.
My family.
They think.
Well, you know, I'm gonna be, I'm gonna be even more
sacrilegious and say that the pizza topping I would order
for you guys is honey drizzled on top.
Wait, I love honey pizza!
Vicky?
Oh, Vicky?
I prefer, I prefer my pizza more savory.
I'm sorry.
I'm a bit funny about like, savory things that taste sweet.
Like, I don't like brioche.
Like, if...
If something is savory, I want it to be savory.
If something is sweet, I want it to be sweet.
I'm sorry.
So honey on pizza is a bit of a, like, gray zone.
I would eat it, but I would prefer, like, I'd prefer a nice
pepperoni.
I'll be honest with you.
Okay.
I mean, I love my pepperoni.
But you get a little pepperoni pizza and you drizzle some
honey on top.
I would just put honey on it.
I love honey.
Well, actually, there's like...
Honey loves you too.
Honey loves Vicky even if Honey...
Honey loves Vicky as well.
Even if Vicky does not love Honey.
I mean, I love Honey, but I just like it with sweet.
Like, okay, the best combo.
The best combo ever.
Chat, there's something about it.
Rosemary's and Honey.
Don't hate it till you try it.
It's the best combination ever.
Yeah, it's so good.
It's so good.
You have told us before that that's your favorite, favorite,
like, honey combination.
Wow.
I just ate.
raspberries yesterday i would have put honey on them if i
know try them with honey try it try it once yeah okay okay
yeah um i tell you what you guys shouldn't have on your
pizza do you want to hear something you shouldn't have on
your pizza what's up yeah have i have i told you this before
about the japanese margarita i think during uh the chain
together stream but mint needs to hear it what is it so the
japanese margarita um collab pizza i had once uh from from
pizza hut japan So imagine this cheese Sour umeboshi jam
instead of tomato sauce No wait Ew instead of tomatoes
Instead of tomato sauce And then instead of pepperoni or big
tomatoes Whole umeboshi Whole umeboshi on the pizza And then
instead of a little bit of garnish Big leaf Shiso leaf And
they call it the Japanese margarita Death penalty I mean
Genuinely it was the worst thing I've ever eaten in my life
So let's move on Yeah That gives me trauma, honestly.
Alright, here we go.
18!
What are your favorite robots?
Mecha was the original intention, but R2D2 or Jenny from My
Life as a Teenage Robot type answers are totally valid as
well.
I know mine.
Say, say.
Go ahead, go ahead.
Oh, no, you said you know yours.
Oh.
B-Max!
I love B-Max.
Oh, B-Max is real.
really cute so cute and fluffy and so kind i remember when i
first watched big hero 6 i just i thought baybacks was so
cute oh i love baybacks yes very very cute what about you
guys uh mine is from uh this series that was only disney
japan her name is drossel von flu flu flu
Drossel.
She's my favorite.
What's this from?
I don't think I've heard of this.
It's from like a show called Fireball.
And it was only Disney Japan.
But it's like super witty and super cute.
And I love it.
I have to check it out.
I'm seeing her.
She's cute.
She's so cute.
I love it.
Fireball.
She's like Hatsune Miku the robot.
Yeah.
I love my robot girls, really robot.
Oh, they kind of sick.
Yeah, okay.
Sorry.
It's Disney.
Please continue.
Oh, they do that.
They do that.
Sorry, please continue.
Phoebe, what is your favorite robot?
Phoebe, what's your favorite about it?
Was it like, is it like robots in general or like robot
characters?
Oh, I think it could be, Eva.
Yeah.
There are these pet robots in Japan that, like, can get
called uh lovots oh my gosh yeah they're very cute and and
there are also little ones called mothlings or something
that's a different oh i've seen these but they have yeah so
they have all these like pet robots that are smart like the
smart ai pet robots in japan and so if i were to ever move
to japan i would want to get them they have personalities
that they can develop you can dress them up and they're like
little babies but if we're talking characters that I think
Talburn from Freakin' Star Driver is the hottest like,
magazine.
The Switch Up!
Oh my gosh, what the love hot!
I once went to, I was like at a department store and they
had a pop-up and I was like looking at them and it felt like
Build-A-Bear because you're right, they have like clothes
and stuff and like it was all like a bunch of accessories
for them and I was like, what the heck is this thing?
Oh, I learned.
Oh, really, very cute.
So any Densetsu fans that live in Japan, I recommend getting
a little baby Lovat for yourself.
Yes, Star Drive, oh, based Densetsu fans, I'm so glad.
I don't know, have you two watched Star Driver?
I didn't.
Star, I thought you said Star Trek.
Also, Star Driver.
No, I...
The main guy's neck.
is so like I do remember it coming out but I didn't watch it
yeah it's so stylish super stylish mech they're everyone in
the show is attractive including the mechs the mechs are
attractive Phoebe I didn't know you rolled like this okay
not usually but Star Driver is a little a little different
I'll have to date your recommendation Talbot Talbot towel
burn.
Towel burn.
Nice.
Yeah.
Towel?
It's got like a feather.
No.
Yeah, towel.
T-A-U-B-U-R-N.
Towel burn.
For real though.
I don't like it.
I don't like it when you get towel burn.
You know when you like, you do the thing, you know when you
do the thing where you've got your big towel and then you
like dry yourself off.
You're like drying off your butt and you like, you like
wiggle from side to side.
Then occasionally it's like a paper cup and you can get a
towel burn.
Has anyone ever got one before?
You can get a towel burn?
Yeah!
From aggressively, like, I don't know, rubbing yourself with
a towel too much.
Why do you need to rub it so hard?
My eyes deliberately.
You know when you're boogeying.
Yeah, I just pat myself down.
You know when you put yourself down.
No, you gotta get your, you know, you gotta get your ass
dry.
But I don't think I've ever...
With my ass?
Yeah, I just boogey naked.
You like boogey.
Oh, no, no.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, you learned a lot about Densetsu today, guys.
Some boogie with their back, some boogie with their bum, and
some boogie with nothing on.
Boogie.
Boogie, boogie.
Question 19.
Vicky, I hear in Britain they dip meat pies into tea for
second breakfast.
Is that real?
Is that true?
I'm scared.
Where on earth have you heard this?
The myths, the myths, the myths.
Why is this filled with British myths?
You guys need to get some education.
on British people.
I've never heard of this.
What do you mean, dip a meat pie into tea?
We would never dip something like that into our cup.
We would never, in the good name of tea, what?
I feel like they might.
I feel like they might, right?
I feel like if someone told me I would believe it, right?
Yeah, I would believe it.
I can imagine it.
I can visualize it.
I know I can visualize it too, yeah, right?
Or maybe it's, maybe I'm just imagining Steiner doing that.
I don't know if Vicky would.
would oh yeah Steiner I think would probably do that but
yeah I feel like you know I feel like something probably
takes over and she just doesn't realize she does it oh yeah
maybe she doesn't remember unless she like it wipes her
memory off yeah yeah it's like I think it's like programmed
yeah yeah it's a good job it's the middle of the night in
the UK right now because I'm sure Steiner would be
incredibly offended by this comment we dip sweet things into
our tea so like tea rich tea biscuits they specifically have
these biscuits well what you call them cookies in the u.s
they have these cookies that are specifically for you know
soaking up the flavor of tea rich tea biscuits so we do do
stuff like that but it's always sweet stuff you never dip a
meat pie into your tea absolutely ridiculous next question
just drink some good tea get some education whoever sent
this question in okay question 20
Steiner here.
Oh, is that him?
Oh, dude.
I'm sorry, Steiner.
I'm sorry.
I'm not.
Steiner, is it true?
Do you do this?
Hope you're having fun dipping the meat pie into the tea
right now.
He's going to say something crazy, like, oh, yeah, sometimes
it'll slip from my hand and it becomes like a meat soup.
He would.
No, no.
okay dipping it in beer though that's kind of different like
dipping it in tea seems like sacrilege to me but dipping a
meat pie in a bit of beer that actually sounds kind of nice
anyway what do you think is the biggest charm point of your
model oh so like our designs i guess and that kind of
question how we look yeah yeah
i like this is something chat with oh sorry go ahead no no
you go ahead because you had an idea my retro cape you can't
see it right now because I've got I've got the reindeer
outfit on but uh that was like a big part of of the of the
design is I wanted it to look very like show a retro uh and
I love my I love my cape yeah I think that's my favorite my
favorite part it is very and my little hat my tiny little
smart hat yes yeah what about you guys
there's so many so many charm points it's hard to pick
Things I like There are so many things I like about it The
name tag What do you mean chat?
What do you mean?
It's just a regular name tag I don't know what you're
talking about I don't know They're into like Names And tags
Wait okay Someone said in chat Said my cheeks And I know
they meant more than just my face But I do like my cheeks on
my face Because It's kind of They're so cute And they're
rosy They're very round I like my round cheeks So sweet I
love the little mint chocolate details On your outfit as
well Like the socks with the chocolate dripping down That's
my favorite So cute Wait that's literally what I was going
to say Really?
The bits of brown That's what I was going to say I've never
met someone Who thinks so much like me So much like me
What about you, Phoebs?
So for me, I think...
See, I would have said, like, ooh, the whole collarbone area
with, like, the little mole and the collarbone area.
But I think...
I think, like, I'm...
The face in general makes me happy, because I feel like I
can do a lot of...
It just feels like it's got a lot of personality.
Yeah!
I like the way that it looks when I'm chewing food.
It reminds me of my bunny.
I love that one clip.
And then the eyebrows.
Yeah.
The one where we were streaming all...
Chained together together.
Oh, that was...
That was cute.
It was so cute.
It was very silly.
He was literally eating like a little bunny.
Little bunny.
Yeah, your mouth like does the trunk.
triangle it's so cute oh yeah so sweet oh for you as well I
really like your like uh sheer lace gloves Phoebe I think
that's what I was gonna say yeah it's really cute I do like
that they don't go all the way down to the fingertips as
well they look more like arm bands yeah it's a kind of a I
like my um my mama a psyche a hero like touched up the
original design a little bit and like decided to change a
few things and The the fact that they're transparent.
I think like the way that they're styled is her
My both of both of you is so so beautiful Thank you question
three of us twenty one By the way, do you do you like these
little advent things?
bought them somewhere for $20.
Yeah, they're cute.
They're really cute.
If you all compete against each other in a bake-off, what
would, oh God, I can't really bake.
So what would be your masterpiece and who do you think would
win?
Congrats on the debut.
Thank you.
Bake-off.
So like the great pretty baby would win.
Yeah, Phoebe's the only one that bakes.
Am I the only one out of the three of us?
I think the thing that made me realize this as well is like
this isn't even baking like when Phoebe put up Did you pop a
picture of like some amazing charcuterie board that
literally looked like the most beautiful thing I've ever
seen in my life when was that?
I'm happy you liked it.
Yeah, I did.
I like to make little roses It was so beautiful and I was
like wow.
I think Phoebe might be so I think the baby's gonna have to
cook for the mom and dad Sorry I'm crazy Sometimes you're
forced to grow up That's so fair.
You know.
But okay, then if by default I win, then between the two of
you.
I don't count.
So let me give you my sort of history in baking.
So I've definitely tried to make some things.
I made a slanting two tiered cake where the top tier fell
off the bottom tier and slide it off.
Trying to think what else?
Not gray basically.
What about you, Minto?
Um, I once made a pre-made gingerbread house.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, and I made pizza with, like, Kiwi and Duryan and candy
corn and corn.
Duryan?
Yeah.
Duryan.
Oh, I've got... I almost threw up to...
I imagine you did.
Oh, I've got another thing.
Yeah, it was a pizza.
Did you guys ever have to do, like, cooking stuff for
school.
Like, in the UK, we had food tech.
And you had to make stuff.
And then, like, your parents or something had to review it
and, like, be like, it's got sweetness, three, and
tastiness, four or something.
My parents refused to eat anything I made.
They knew.
I made some awful stuff.
No, they refused, flat out, to eat anything that I made.
So that also gives you an idea of my skills.
yeah oh maybe i'd come in the middle then yeah i think
probably i'd come last i reckon i'm still the breadwinner i
love this the baby's cooking for both parents and then the
mother takes care of everything in the house except except
the cooking and then and the minto's like you know like a
little bit of a We're good at everything.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Give me a wrench.
Thanks, thanks, Dad.
Thanks, baby.
I got you.
Very nice, very nice.
Question, we've got three more questions left of the
marshmallow advent.
Then you guys get a surprise.
Question 22.
Oh, surprise.
On the 22nd day of advent.
On the 22nd day of advent, mine.
Did you watch any dub?
It's my mother gave to me.
A really awful meal.
Did you watch any dubbed anime on TV as a kid?
What was your favorite?
Did you guys watch dubbed anime?
I did.
Four Kids TV.
You see, I don't really have that as much.
I feel like I didn't have the channels that had anime on it.
I had to wait till I went to a friend's house and be like,
Oh yeah, Dexter's Laboratory.
That was me with Disney.
Oh, yeah.
No, I didn't.
No, I had the basic channels.
Bit of CBBC, that was it.
You guys don't even know what that is.
But yeah, yeah.
I had the basic channels.
But I did, they did show, they did show Pokemon.
So I did watch Pokemon when I was a kid.
But I think that was maybe the only thing.
Yeah, because there just wasn't many options.
But you guys.
I think Pokemon is a solid choice though.
I think that's a lot of our first like dog anime.
Yeah.
I also really like the Sailor Moon dub.
Like I think the way they're like Serena.
Yeah.
And she would be like, oh my goodness I'm so sorry.
I hit the end and I just feel like it.
It was fun.
I don't think I've ever seen it, but I want to see it.
after that serena yeah it's like iconic serena serena these
donuts are great she was serena yeah name changes the name
changes what about you fevers there's a lot of like a lot of
stuff that was on like 4Kids and all that so like yeah Sonic
X had the anime with the dogs There's like Yu-Gi-Oh!
Oh, yeah!
Uh, Yu-Gi-Oh, and oh wait, there was like, there was some
magical girl stuff too, like, Ojama Joe Doremi, or magic,
sorry, magical Doremi.
Not Tokyo Mew-Mew, but Mew-Mew Power.
Mew-Mew-Mew Power.
Oh my god, I watched a lot of Duel Masters.
I've loved that show too.
It's like the one- Duel Masters!
Yeah, it's like the one, like, card game that, like, I don't
know, I don't think it's took off so much.
I don't know if it's so popular with the kids.
Such a long...
Wait, it's not Yu-Gi-Oh, it's something else?
Yeah, it's Duel Masters.
Oh, I've never heard of it.
I wonder if it's still a franchise at all.
I have no idea.
Oh, do, do.
Oh, man, you guys have Sonic X.
I'm so jealous.
In the UK, you are...
If you... It was like a...
Like, you got...
With Disney Channel, you also got the channel that had Sonic
X on it, and I never had that.
Oh, lucky.
all right and he still somehow got sonic peeled yeah it was
once i got access to the internet played my first sonic game
i was like amazing okay blade mentioned in the chat oh i
still really like bayblade as well oh bayblade yeah you had
a big one and be doing bayblade i like a bayblade yes how
many babe do you do do Bayblade battles, Phoebe?
I do sometimes.
Sometimes when I go to performances, somebody will have
their Bayblade stuff.
Actually, a recent check-y I got to take at U.S.
Idol Fest was somebody just pulled out their entire Bayblade
arena thing.
And we...
No way!
They took the check-y as soon as we, like, let it rip.
It was great.
I lost, I think.
Is that what you say with Bayblades?
Let it rip.
yeah yeah makes me think of something else but anyway that's
a tagline makes me think of a little don't think about it
don't think about it uh i'm currently buying a pack of
peanut m&ms as i type this i can't think of anything better
so if you had to choose one snack to have for the rest of
your life or afterlife what would it be i'm a ride or die
for peanut m&ms geez do you think peanut M&Ms.
I think I think maybe they do.
You want some more peanut M&Ms?
You didn't get enough, clearly.
Yeah.
Peanut M&Ms on the brain.
Do you guys have an answer to this one?
I think I do have a quite quick answer, actually.
Yeah.
Olives.
I love olives.
I'm sorry.
I think the thing with olives is I never get tired of them.
Like, I could just have a bowl of them all the time and i
never get tired of them i have them with my lunch on my
salad every day love them i could have them forever and
never get bored sorry mento now i know i feel like i've
offended mento i'll give all the olives to you yeah yeah
yeah wait neither of you like olives yeah yeah yeah what
about you guys what about you mento do you have one i think
mine would be The Manan Life Konyak Jelly Packets that you
can get at Konbini.
I think I would eat that for the rest of my life.
No.
Yeah.
I love...
I just love jelly.
Jellies are good.
Do they flavor the Konyak?
Yeah.
I specifically like the grape one.
So it's like...
Oh, it's so yummy.
And it's like healthy.
Yeah, it's better for you.
Yeah.
Olives and cognac jellies.
Both reasonably healthy options, to be fair.
Yeah, well, if I were to choose a, like, a savor, more
savory option, it would be, like, the super cheesy
cheez-its.
Oh.
Like the cheddar blast cheez-its.
Oh, those are good.
Oh.
I don't, I've never had those, but I guess an equivalent.
In the UK, I would go for quavers.
Do you know what, do you know, quavers?
They're, like, really, like, curly cheesy crisp i think
you'd like them i think you'd like them if you like cheese
it's yeah i'll bring you some cheese it's next time i'll
bring you some quaver's when i go back okay heck yeah i'll
bring the cheese puffs cheese balls the cheese balls i saw
all of y'all trying to see how many cheese ball tubs hi i am
i was how how many did you get for you I'm well so I did end
up like We measured it We measured it at Anime Week in
Atlanta We stacked it We used someone's credit card to make
sure that we were putting the Putting the The tub down in
the right place I'm like about four About four Cheeseball
tubs I guess So people's calculations were correct Yeah You
know, I was once given, I was also once given, gifted a
cheeseball tub of the same sort.
And I ate through that cheeseball tub.
And I have not had a cheeseball ever since because I said, I
am good for the rest of my afterlife.
I will never need another cheeseball.
And so I felt a little trauma through your cheeseball
journey.
Do you think that's really the aim?
back traumatizing memories oh no yes are the people giving
you these cheeseballs oh oh no go ahead i was just gonna ask
if they're cheeseball lovers or cheeseball haters for giving
you these you know maybe they maybe they're like yeah if we
give them this they'll never want cheeseballs ever again
yeah yeah it's a very good question you'll never want it
again I promise maybe maybe I need to finish the tub first
and exactly how I feel But maybe I'll just be sad.
Maybe I'll miss it.
And in which case that would be the answer to this question.
If not, probably like, I don't know, cookies.
I can always go for a good chocolate chip cookie.
Maybe you can keep a diary about how you're feeling about
cheeseballs.
Every cheeseball you take from the tub.
Maybe.
It's day 300.
There is still half the tub of cheeseballs.
How am I feeling about it?
I have to rate it on a scale.
of one to five every day, how I'm feeling about the
cheeseballs.
Oh my gosh, you know how there's like diaries where you do
like kind of like say, like it says like, what's your mood
today and things like that?
You can get one specifically made for cheeseball like
documentation.
That's been my new mission in 2026 is to document my
experience with its cheeseballs.
And you could sell it as goods as a memoir.
The cheeseball memoir.
I need to be honest though.
I now have Two tubs of cheese balls.
So, let me just say.
You're not going to make it.
Someone ordered a surprise gift for me on a throne.
And it was the cheese balls.
And then at Anime Week in Atlanta, another fan gifted me a
tub of cheese balls.
The same tub of cheese balls.
So, I now have two.
whole tubs of Oots cheese balls.
Thank you everybody that's half my size.
Yippee!
Wow.
Well good luck with that.
In the meantime it's our last advent guys.
25!
We're nearly at 25.
Oh my god we're here.
Would you punch one of your fans for one million dollars?
That's a great question to finish off.
That's a great question.
in my question for this is are they into it right right
that's what i'm thinking there would probably be so many
that that would be like yes please please please pick me my
lord because if it's gonna make them sad or hurt them then
like no i don't i would not for a billion dollars but if
they're if it makes them happy even makes them smile yeah
there's got to be at least one right in each of our fan
bases that like wants that to happen really bad and then we
all get a million bish bash bush everyone's happy yeah yeah
yeah me me there seems to be a lot of people saying me me me
so i think so i think that's a resounding yes then we would
punch you for a million dollars yeah yeah and with that you
guys we're moving on to the 25th krimus surprise krimus
surprise okay guys now what i have got for you guys is a
game show so i'm gonna quickly go to the loading while i
prepare the game show ready to go let me get your little
gonna get your little podiums okay there we go this looks
good okay okay um choto choto a minute people which corner
am i gonna start with that's a great question let's do one
okay welcome to vicky's krimus quiz our first corner is the
lyrics are chicken yes that's right the lyrics are chicken
um so we're gonna have three different rounds each with
three questions that you guys are gonna have some points up
for grabs and we're gonna see the winner today.
Minto or Phoebe.
The first round is the lyrics are chicken.
You're going to hear some famous Krimmer songs.
And some of the lyrics are replaced by a chicken.
And you've got to say what the lyrics are.
Let's first decide what you want for your buzzer noises.
So you guys can decide on a little buzzer noise for each of
you.
What are you guys going to do?
Oh, should we, like, open our soundboard?
Oh, if you have some, that'd be great.
But if you don't know what you can just do it with your
mouth.
I'll do it with my mouth.
I'll do it with like a...
Oh, cute.
Okay, so we've got the doot-oot.
And I'll do...
That sounds very similar.
Chat, can you tell which one is different?
Oh.
I can do...
Okay, doot-oot.
It's like...
It's like from Science Gate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then Phoebe, what's yours again?
I'll go.
Oh, no, I'll do it myself.
Pikmin!
Okay, Pikmin and Tuttu!
Okay, got it.
Pikmin and Tuttu!
So it is the first to be able to answer.
Now, the way that we're going to do this, guys, is Choto a
minute.
The music's going to go out for one sec, chat, while I just
quickly test with everybody that everything is working.
So, both of you, I want you to...
tell me if just my dad I want you guys to tell me if you can
hear this uh cremas music can you hear this cremas music oh
oh oh yes it's pretty quiet but I can hear it is quiet oh
yes it is very oh oh okay yeah that's bad I don't know why
it was on like 10 volume okay okay all right then in that
case in that case we are ready we are ready to go so the
first question by the way no looking at chat no cheating
either of you no cheating chat you are allowed to guess
along as well but do not give them the answers okay question
wait chat said they can't hear it It was while I was
testing.
They will be able to hear it now.
Okay, okay, okay.
They will be able to hear it.
Ah, okay.
Okay.
Question one.
Question one coming in now.
Remember, it's the first to buzz in with the correct lyric.
Santa cutie and fill my stocking.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Bend?
Yes, Pikmin?
With the duplex and checks.
That means we have one point of...
I realize I should probably keep track of the points
somehow.
Give me a second, Chad.
Let me just add a quick little point system.
Yubi!
Okay, well done, Phoebe.
That gives Phoebe one point already.
She's evolving like a Pokemon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One point to Phoebe.
Minto, you need to, you know, you need to...
Step up your game to be able to get some points in this
round.
1.2, Phoebe.
Alright, are we ready?
Are we ready for the next part?
Here we go.
Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa baby.
So, it's the bit specifically after that.
Maybe this is too hot.
It's the bit specifically after the...
Maybe no Googling.
No Googling.
No Googling, okay?
Okay, you ready to go again?
Ready to go again, you guys?
Wait, is the stream alive?
Wait, is the stream?
Oh, one second.
What's happening?
Is the snowy background maybe making the stream like five
frames per second possible?
Yeah, it's really...
Possibly.
What's happening?
The stream is lagging.
The stream is at least it's choppy.
The video itself.
Oh, yes.
Okay, it's not choppy in my OBS, but I can see that it's
choppy.
Okay, interesting.
Be glad.
Is it maybe the animated background?
Hmm, interesting.
I know, it's interesting because it's not like it's very
different than what it was earlier.
Yeah, it's no problem on my end, interesting.
uh obs doesn't have an issue either is it youtube it started
once you started the audio do you think it's that for some
reason but it's it i feel like then obs would be lagging obs
is not lagging at all i feel like it might be i feel like it
might be youtube oh okay it started only after the music the
music Oh.
How do I do that?
Audio is good, though, they said.
Oh, audio is good?
That's very odd.
Okay, let me go to loading screen and see if there's
anything I can do.
Okay.
Otherwise, it's nice that the audio is...
Oh, it suddenly got okay for me.
Oh, yeah, me too.
Me too.
Oh, me too.
What?
Okay.
What happened?
Did anything change?
Maybe YouTube had a bit of an issue for some reason.
Because nothing...
I think YouTube...
change yeah i think it might have been youtube can you guys
hear now okay all right very odd yeah i haven't had any
change on obs side so i think it might just be a temporary
youtube issue okay i think it was a youtube day can you guys
see now is it all good okay not sure what happened frames
are back okay we back not sure what happened there so sorry
chat so sorry can you guys see now can you see us we moving
we grooving we move and we grooving all seems fine audio was
good okay that makes me think it might be a youtube thing
then yeah because i'm not sure what was going on there yeah
my computer and my internet is definitely fine so i think it
might have been a short problem with the YouTube.
Sorry about that.
Yes.
Okay.
We are back.
We are back and ready to go.
Okay.
And the lyrics are chicken.
Yes.
The lyrics are chicken.
Okay.
Here we go.
Are you ready guys?
Let's see if you guys can get a point.
Okay.
Maybe that one was too hard.
Let's try a slightly easier one.
Okay.
Let's try this one.
Think of all The fun I've missed
Yes, yes, to-through To-through Think of all the fellas that
I haven't kissed Zika Well done, Minto That brings Minto up
to one point as well Let me just get a quick point system
going One point for Minto Mint, Mint Point Which brings us
to one point each so far.
How are we feeling?
Level pegging right now, chat.
Who do we think is going to win?
Well, there are many more questions to come, so we will have
to see.
All right.
Here we go.
Question two for the chicken.
Are you guys ready?
You guys ready?
I'm chicken.
Here we go.
On the third day of Christmas, my true love sent to me.
Two turtle doves and a partridge in a pear tree On the third
day of Christmas my true love sent to me Two turtle doves
and a partridge in a pear tree Any ideas?
Take a guess, take a guess Okay, tuturu, yes
Dorians, two turtle doves, and a partridge And a partridge
No, no, no, no No, no, so much I might even give you minus
points for that Phoebe I
Pip, pick, pick, pick, pick, baby Yes, yes, yes Okay, wait,
wait, no, it was not turtle doves Wait, the three French
hands Three French hands, two turtle doves a portrait and
I'll play a tree.
Zika!
Yes, Phoebe has three French hens, which means Phoebe gets
another point.
And then you said two turtle dubs, and I was like, oh, I
thought it was turtle dubs, too.
Yeah.
I realize every time I press a number, it's changing my
reindeer hood, so please, please, please just ignore that.
You're, like, evolving like a Pokemon.
It's so funny.
Question to, along a similar line, I will say.
On the sixth day of Christmas, my true love sent to me.
Five gold rings.
Should I play it again?
See if anything, see if anything jogs your memory.
Anyone in chat, anyone in chat got it.
Anyone in chat got it yet, I wonder.
I keep thinking turtle doves.
I never think the turtle doves.
I was like, four turtle doves.
Three turtle doves Two turtle doves And a turtle doves
Alright let's play it again Six, six What do we think?
Okay On the sixth day of Christmas My true love sent to me
Five gold rings Oh, Pikmin, Pikmin Oh, yes, Phoebe Is it
six?
Six eggs are laying.
Oh, yes, yes.
No, you're so close, but that is wrong.
Mint, do you want to take a guess along a similar line?
Six maidens dancing.
No.
Phoebe is so close.
There's a maiden dancing, though, right?
Phoebe was so close.
Am I close?
You're so close, Phoebe.
It's not six eggs are laying.
Six turtle dogs.
Final answer.
Who could be laying the eggs?
Who's laying the eggs?
Oh, oh, the geese!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Phoebe is!
Phoebe's...
Six Phoebe's are laying.
Wait, no.
No!
Six, six geese are laying.
Six geese are laying!
Thank you!
Well done, that means Phoebe.
Yeah, sorry, eggs don't lay their eggs.
Yeah, eggs don't lay themselves.
at least they don't at the moment maybe in the future what
mind blown mind blown okay one last one on this question
here we go on the 8th day of Christmas my true love sent to
me seven swans are swimming on the 8th day of Christmas my
true love sent to me 8 that was a good good clue So close.
Not quite.
It's not maidens.
Oh, cows milking.
You're so close.
With eight maidens milking.
It's eight maidens milking, right?
Okay, right.
What do you get?
What's like maiden but not maiden?
If you take off some letters from maiden.
Oh.
yeah you want to buzz oh are you buzzing minto okay do do
yes eight maids of milking eight maids of milking say yes
eight maids of milking well done minto that brings us nearly
nearly to even points i think nearly nearly but not quite
all right the last question of the chicken round how many
people in chat are getting yeah people people are saying
eight eight no not meadows eight maids uh all right third
question chat will you get it quicker than phoebe and minto
let's find out here we go let's see rocking around the
christmas tree at the christmas party hub
I thought of the wrong part.
Shall I play it again?
See if it jogs your memory.
Here we go.
Rocking around the Christmas tree at the Christmas party
hop.
Yes, toototot, yes.
Everyone's shouting and kicking to the beat.
Merrily.
Christmas party rock.
no no that is not correct rocking around the Christmas tree
mint sounding kind of like how you know you get this really
awful like AI recreations of Christmas songs I think it's
something like this rockin dancing right okay let's play it
again rocking around the Christmas tree at the Christmas
party hub I can't remember.
My brain is going to the wrong part of the song.
I know it's wrong.
Because everyone's dancing merrily is not the right...
Oh, wait, is that not it?
Oh, Phoebe, yep, yep.
Oh, um, Mesutohang, where you can't see.
Sing!
Mesutohang, where you can't see.
Well done, Phoebe, that's another point.
I don't remember the line after.
That's another point to you.
Thank God I didn't have to do the part afterwards.
Well, lucky for you, there's more.
another question from this song here we go you will get a
sentimental feeling when you hear voices singing let's be
jolly yes yes yes oh no wait hold on take the halls with
brows of holly yeah well done well done mean tall that
brings it up to three four this is a close game guys it
really is anyone's it really is anyone's game you don't know
what rounds you don't know what rounds are coming yet
rocking around the christmas tree have a happy holiday
everyone dancing merrily okay yes pickman yes in the new
old-fashioned way Hi, well done, Phoebe.
And that brings us at the end of the lyrics a chicken round,
the current victor is Phoebe.
But we have two rounds to go, so it could really be anyone's
game.
All right, let's put up a quick cheeky poll.
Who will win?
I was going to vote for Phoebe.
Minto.
I don't know about that, dude.
I don't know about that.
You don't know what rounds are coming, guys.
It could really be anyone's...
We're not going to be chicken anymore.
No.
It's time for the next round, which is...
Why is it so British?
So for this round, everyone, I'm going to be reading the
lyrics of some popular Christmas songs.
You are going to have to guess which song these are from,
but I will not be singing the lyrics.
I will simply be reading them in this voice, and you will
have to guess which song this is from.
Okay.
Are you ready, Mint and Phoebe, and chat?
We?
Yes,
yes, I'm ready.
I think I'm feeling quite ready.
Are you as ready as you are going to be?
As we are going to be.
Yes.
Here we go then.
Please forgive me.
The British iPad is being very slow.
Please bear with me.
the british experience yes this is also part of the whole
experience absolutely um oh my gosh why is it being so slow
right um oh god it's literally like completely frozen again
give me give me a second guys i'm trying in the meantime
what do you what did you think of the chicken uh chicken
quiz so far guys i love chicken quiz was it everything you
ever dreamed of Oh, I'm glad you liked it.
Oh, oh, yeah.
You want to put that rubber chicken on the grill?
Yeah.
I don't think it would taste that good.
On the barbie.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
Are you ready?
So we're just guessing the song, right?
Yes.
Okay.
And when I'm feeling alone, you remind me of home.
Oh, baby, baby.
Merry Christmas and when the world isn't fair I pretend that
we're there baby baby Merry Christmas to you yes minto
frosty the snowman incorrect incorrect any guesses from
Phoebe otherwise we will go to a slightly more recognizable
part of the song.
I mean, Rudolph.
The red nose.
Incorrect.
So we will go to a different pie.
Sweet dreams of Holly and Ribbon.
Mistakes are forgiven.
And everything is icy and blue.
And you would be there too sweet dreams of holly and ribbon
I don't mistakes are forgiven and everything is icy and blue
and you would be there too chat seems to also be struggling
okay we're gonna oh yes go for it Minto white Christmas
incorrect any more guesses from Phoebe before we move on.
Is this a Michael Boublaze song at least?
Maybe.
No, it's not.
Okay.
I know this one.
Oh, some people in chat have got it.
Some people have got it.
Okay.
This is much harder than I thought it would be.
Yeah, that's the way this corner works.
Then you hear the song and you're like, oh!
Okay.
In my heart is a Christmas tree farm.
There's a light in the barn.
We'd Run inside, out from the cold.
In the town, kids are dreaming of slays.
And they're warm, and they're safe.
They wake to see a blanket of snow.
I don't think you guys are good.
If you can't get it from that, I don't think you're going to
get it.
Gosh, I'm so sorry.
I have no freaking clue.
It was Christmas Tree Farm by Taylor Swift.
Oh, no wonder I didn't.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry This is a classic I'm sorry guys But unfortunately
You did not get that one Let's try one a little bit easier
How about that Let's try a little Slightly more classic one
Okay Okay Okay thank you Okay Okay Okay Okay Okay Okay Let's
go for This one Okay Okay, everyone, chat, are you ready?
Are you ready as well?
We are currently on the why is it so British corner where
Phoebe and Minto have to guess the song where I simply speak
the lyrics in this voice.
Okay.
Gone away is the bluebird.
Here to stay.
Is the newbird.
Oh, the pigmen!
Yes.
I forgot my alarm sound for a second.
Um, walking in a winter wonderland.
Ah!
I could remember the name of the song.
Yes, it's winter wonderland.
Well done, Phoebe.
That gives you a point to bring you up to six.
Well done.
Okay, we're going to do one more in this round.
Okay.
Let's do this.
I don't know if you guys are going to know this one either,
but...
It'll be funny.
Okay.
She's already mad at me.
Right.
Here we go.
Everyone's gathering around the fire.
Chestnuts roasting like a hot July.
I should be chilling with my folks.
I know.
But I'ma be under the mistletoe.
With you, Shorty.
With you.
What?
Shorty.
with you shorty with you with you under the mistletoe with
you shorty with you okay pickman yes um i know it's justin
beaver hold on um justin beaver is a christmas song with you
sorry what is it called though oh would you like me to read
more of the lyrics so you can guess what i will say is the
song title lyrics.
Okay, I'm going to read it here.
Oh, keep going.
Keep going.
Is it shorty with you?
It's not called shorty with you.
Stop it!
Okay.
For the buzzer, for the buzzer.
Remember guys, buzz in if you know the answer.
Okay.
Word on the street.
Santa's coming tonight.
Ranges flying through the sky so high.
I should be making a list.
I know.
But I'm going to be under the mistletoe.
Yes.
Under the mistletoe?
So close, but unfortunately no.
Pickman?
Yes.
Mistletoe?
Simply mistletoe by Justin Bieber.
Well done.
Man, it's not called Shoddy with you.
Shoddy with you.
So.
At the end of round two, that brings us to 7-3.
It's going to take quite a lot for Minto to be able to bring
this back, but there is still a chance.
And because of that, I'm going to make the last round.
Double points!
So if Minto is able to get some of these, then Minto could
take it at the end.
In fact, why not we do triple points?
All on nothing.
Let's put it all out on the line.
All right, guys.
This is huge.
Triple points.
The last corner today is called.
Can you speak chipmunk?
Okay.
So what we're going to be doing is you guys are going to
hear So this is back to the audio thing, so if you guys
could prepare that.
This is going to be various different songs, but very fast.
So there's going to be a hard mode, which will give you
three points, a medium mode, which will give you two points,
and an easy mode, which will give you one point.
You have to guess what the song is from these.
We're going to start with the hard mode for the first song.
Are you guys ready?
yes yes here we go chat play along as well here we go
a frame dying again oh no i wonder if it is the audio i
wonder if it is the audio if it's this hang on give me a
second what the hell was that i'm gonna take off the video i
wonder if it's like to do the video can you hear me can you
hear us now no latency has returned okay let me i wonder if
it's that video what about now hello everyone i'm sorry i
don't know what's up with it hello are we back are we bad it
was the important part now anyway are we back are we back
Can you hear us from the other side?
Hello.
I don't know.
Never met someone who thinks much like me.
Jinx, Jinx again.
Ah, we didn't hear you.
It's just a bit...
Yeah, it's so weird.
It's fine on my OBS, so I think it might be that YouTube's
having some issues.
I think YouTube may be having some issues.
Hello.
Okay, audio is okay.
is fine okay good to good to know good to know hello hello
can you get me eros hello can you eros okay the music sounds
like the music is very cute the music is very cute indeed we
can hear you just running at five seconds per frame okay we
should catch up soon i hope yeah hopefully we will we will
wait until i mean to be fair this whole portion we can kind
of do like a radio show so maybe it's fine to continue
that's true yeah what do you think okay let's just let's
just do it okay yeah so this is hard mode any ideas so far
what i will say this is a famous christmas song that you
guys will know the end of this i think is the most telling
the end part you can really hear it i think you can Anyways,
I'll play it one more time.
Okay.
Any ideas?
Chat, any ideas?
Oh, yeah.
Is it the Ariana Grande Santa Baby or is there?
Oh gosh, what's her last?
That's just not called.
Santa something.
It is not.
It's not sad to tell me by Ariana Grande.
Oh, okay.
It's not sad to tell me.
Phoebe, any guesses before we move on to the next one?
Oh, um...
Oh, maybe it's not Jingle Bells.
Is it Jingle Bells?
It is not Jingle Bells.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to play the medium
version.
Anyone?
Some people in chat have got it.
Do not look at chat.
Chat are cheating.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
It's last Christmas!
It is last Christmas!
So that's two points.
That's two points.
And because it's triple points, you're on nine!
Oh my god!
Because you got triple points there and you came in at the
medium.
one which is two points already so you get six points which
puts you on nine the tables have turned the tables have
completely turned the tables have turned can i hear the easy
one uh yes you can you can indeed yes you can let's listen
to it let's listen once again and swish i'll keep my
distance before you still catch my eye come baby do you
recognize me what is here doesn't surprise me the christmas
are right even in the hard version you can hear just about
you can hear special yes yes yes um oh everything okay check
no feet oh can you guys still hear us oh i don't know what's
wrong with it can you guys still hear us hello hello hello
hello audio is cutting out too no come on don't cut us out
if i press stop streaming and then start again then it's
gonna mess up the thing right isn't it it's gonna start a
new yeah i think we just wait for it to just gotta wait for
it i'm so sorry guys i don't know no don't be sorry youtube
is cursed but this is kind of a chance for me to go run to
the bathroom okay that's okay let's wait for it to catch up
and go for a quick a quick be right back yeah let's do that
like the brb screen or something yeah i did yeah so vrb guys
while it's sorting itself out
Hi guys, we're back!
And hopefully the stream is also now back.
Fingers crossed.
Can you guys see us?
Can you guys hear us?
Yeah, how's it doing?
Yeah.
At the very least, can you hear us okay?
At the very least.
We have two more questions to go, so hopefully, even if you
guys can hear, it'll be like a radio show.
Yeah!
Hopefully, hopefully.
Can you guys?
T-Rush.
Okay, they're saying...
Oh?
Hmm...
Audio is still cutting.
It's definitely not getting better.
Oof.
Okay.
Why?
Can you guys hear us?
Well, apparently even the loading screen was laggy too.
Yeah, it looks like it.
It is.
Not sure why it would do that.
This is...
It's not like we're doing...
Yeah, I'm not sure.
Trying to think of anything.
Maybe...
Audio jumped, right?
Yeah, the problem is if I refresh, then it'll start a new
thing.
Audio should be better now.
Well, the audio is better than...
then... then that's good.
Okay, audio is still cutting out, but music clear.
That is interesting.
Audio is fine.
Oh, we can hear you.
Audio is clear.
Cool.
Okay.
Okay, audio is good.
Okay, then let's just finish the quiz part.
I'm so sorry, guys, for the...
For the issues.
But we'll quickly finish the quiz.
All right.
It's still been so fun.
I'm glad you guys are enjoying it.
All right, we're going for the hard version first.
us let's see if you guys can get it here we go here we go
any ideas so far guys any ideas or should we go to the media
more Pikmin?
I lost my kazoo.
Oh, there it is.
So, like, I know I guessed this last time.
Maybe I'm just...
Hit the jingle bells this time.
Oh.
Jingle bell rock!
Okay, let's just hear the easy...
Let's hear the easy one.
Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell.
Oh my god!
Dancing, dancing in jingle bell square.
In forest, yeah.
But right time, it's right time.
Rock the night.
Which means...
3 at triple points which means 9 points which means their
favorite is on 16 oh my gosh this is so intense it could go
either way these triple points are crazy man these triple
points are crazy depending on this last the last question
guys the last question all right here we go here we go
Oh yeah, Minto?
Go for it.
No, what's the clue for?
Someone in chat said sounds Japanese.
You might be right oh never mind doesn't it yeah go for it
minto you gotta you gotta guess oh i lot well it was an
english guess so now i'm like oh uh snow halation
you got it which means
That's nine whole points for Minto, which means Minto is on
18, which means the winner is, in a shock turn of events,
Minto!
Oh, by two points.
Those triple points really just made all the difference at
the end there.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
incredible incredible stuff you are the winner of the
christmas quiz minto how do you feel uh feeling festive
let's go all right probably because of the issues we'll have
to get going very soon but just want to quickly say have you
guys ordered your dead set so much much much don't forget
that sales end on the 30 1st of december so if you have not
got your orders in yet do not miss out and go and check it
out yes personally i i'm incredibly excited for the little
heads i was just about to say i want to see so many little
headbands please absolutely uh just so adorable i'm so
excited so very sorry about the slight technical issues
towards the end you guys but i hope that you enjoyed This
festive Densetsu Advent and festive Christmas quiz.
Anything you guys want to quickly announce before we head
off?
Thank you.
Subscribe to Densetsu channel.
Yeah.
Listen to Densetsu MVPs.
Please do.
Thank you guys for a wonderful, wonderful first.
Like, I mean, this is our first Christmas and our first New
Year's together.
I hope that we'll get to celebrate lots, lots more together.
with Minto and Vicky and me and also with you guys and yeah,
go get, go grab your merch that ends on the 31st so that's
coming up technically my my vinyls and stuff also end on the
31st as well so go get those go get it go get it egg yeah
brandy old barkers we've got memberships watch along later
today for me but I guess tomorrow for some of you as well if
you want to go check that we're gonna have a fun festive
watch log heck yeah heck yeah and with that happy holidays
whether you celebrate or not i hope you're having a lovely
festive period and from all of us and then said to exe we
wish you a very very happy holidays thank you so much chat
happy hi